who's gonna sign her at least got
convinced to get [ __ ] a hiss I'm a
waitress from genuis my dream in the
unborn story
oh [ __ ] it's the Lord's Day you thought
I forgot about you [ __ ] I've been
busy I've been doing [ __ ] all [ __ ]
day right readin a [ __ ] jiu-jitsu
class I had the baby at the park she
talked me into taking of the munchies
you know it never ends in my world but
don't worry I didn't forget about you
filthy [ __ ] animals why cuz I love
you that's why we got some reefer here
this is this [ __ ] that [ __ ] Trump
smoked when he found out he wasn't gonna
get in trouble with the Russians this
[ __ ] he gave Milania they eat that ass
speaking of ass where's Jeff Sessions
Act
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh you baggy [ __ ] least I had
his back from Miami Beach [ __ ] dock
de cuisine he was at the show last night
looking for you oh I know worried about
you he's gonna ETS and letters for you I
said let me tell you something this
[ __ ] is solid as the Rock of
Gibraltar
Paul is gone machine didn't go missing
yet and I'm saying
she doesn't have missing yet if you
ain't sparking today get the [ __ ] off
the periscope Phil you understand me
does this is deepness to the deepness
deepness to the deepness on the eve of
my 55th birthday we're going deep
tonight I don't give a [ __ ] if they
drink an ammonia
yeah I'm saying I'm Mounier with some
[ __ ] cigarettes I did that one time
tremendous are you ready another one for
you nothing it's like a slim fast [ __ ]
[Music]
once that goes along but who's who needs
one you know I'm saying who's working
and [ __ ] live forever if you 18 hang
up now you little [ __ ] I'm
watching you you over there [ __ ]
thinking about doing [ __ ] you're doing
dick you little [ __ ] something you're
two days from being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
anyway will you kid we're going deep
into the medical hemispheres Lee has
some Chinese food
it's not like these [ __ ] that's what
I'm talking about you don't say that's
the way you're making appearance with a
new head do the Ben Franklin hairdo is
done [ __ ] the kite you know I'm saying
I'm back whether you kidding me or what
is the show a deck right here tonight
[ __ ] you've been looking for
uncle joy got a lot of things to them
with the church I took care of
everything we got different reefers from
all over the [ __ ] world in this damn
e we got [ __ ] nicotine gum
we got Russian weed from sunset oh boy
look at this I could get myself my saw
when he can't juggle all the [ __ ]
edible packages we got tonight and where
you at got something at home in the
living room when my handle in my life
you know what I don't give a [ __ ] if
your grandfather fell down and broke his
hip go take one of his oxycontin let's
get this party started [ __ ] it's the
Lord's Day look look at this double bad
and I come at you with this over here
creeping while you're sleeping you know
I'm saying not even black people do that
[ __ ] speaking of black people I hope you
had a nice time last night the all-star
game you jumped up and down everything's
good you know
saying you ever see when an all-star
game comes to town it turns into [ __ ]
Africa I love it they're everywhere
pimps everything they got everything
salute to the brothers Martin Luther
King
Kobe [ __ ] what's his name Brian yeah
whatever whatever he's still playing it
hard this is LA this is his
[ __ ] City and magic was out
there spreading that HIV I heard
drinking glasses and people is [ __ ] the
[ __ ] I'm saying [ __ ] you and me we'll
make love blue you ready to rock or what
I don't wanna get old stories next up
we're going deep you doing 10 minutes to
the night so we're going deep this is
I'm throwing you in the deep end with no
we got we got I mean listen when you
with me something happens we got an
Armenian uber driver he'll he see a tip
top module and he turns the clock back
and everything you follow me slow way
but not I got you covered
I got you covered no worries then I got
a surprise me at the Comedy Store a big
surprise one of your favorite things in
the world coming to the Comedy Store
that I mean listen to me
you can't even figure out what I got
coming for the commies girl for you
tonight Dunkin Donuts suck see I'm
talking about he always that talk about
something that raises my [ __ ] blood
pressure
why would I nail Dunkin Donuts when I
got the mixing is over it [ __ ] you
who what's naming yum yum oh my god
tremendous dog doughnuts those are the
best doughnuts in the world just don't
go on in and ask for the caloric intake
a lot of white people go in there and
they want to know if he's got [ __ ]
gluten you're gonna get one answer
chocolate chocolate eat the [ __ ]
donut could be strawberry it's that
Mexican don't give a [ __ ] chocolate and
he just smiles yeah chocolate now you
see the Mexicans last week they all had
hearing aids on cuz Isis was visiting
every Mexican had hearing aids are you
could talk to every time a Mexican heard
a siren last week they went [ __ ]
bananas they went everywhere
they will stop in Mexicans on the trains
why because they wanted to give him a
[ __ ] welcome package good they want
to kick him out
how about Trump they want to trouble
they were down at Hollywood and Vine
lee-sia waiting for Mexicans to get off
the trains and arrest them grab the
trains Mexicans had [ __ ] beards on
they were posing as Arabs they even out
like a stick of dynamite out of just in
case you don't say Jeff [ __ ] Habib
chocolate yeah what ice shows up Mexican
that comes up over the Mexican radio
Telemundo Telemundo Telemundo Isis last
week every Mexican had a [ __ ] there
was some one of those Warren's walking
around because they didn't have the
money for the batteries for the [ __ ]
watching me watching every move then get
all [ __ ] it's the Lord's Day
[ __ ] if you ain't [ __ ]
sniffing [ __ ] tonight suck my dick go
hang out with the [ __ ] mom oh by the
way I want to give a shout out to my man
[ __ ] Ali Siddiq I started to flunk
and Swiss Miss diet ready to go listen
for nights I'm the third night let me
tell you what happened he said that
everything comes out of your body from
the last 30 years I told you the third
day listen I can't [ __ ] I got that dick
but I've been asking [ __ ] for years let
me tell you something eyeball a head
came out of my ass like a head ball 30
years of eatin ass it looked like a
werewolf in my toilet and I'm saying so
a big shout-out to Swiss Chris you took
all the [ __ ] pubic out of my system I
have little hairs I have this afro hair
from 1980 [ __ ] four I used to eat
this blank check out with a hairy [ __ ]
tremendous you understand me I used to
just chunk about I used to just inhale
those pubic heads you would just eat a
pic you ever just swallow up pubic hair
that's what savages do you [ __ ] and
I'll shave your [ __ ] I don't like it I
want everything you understand me I want
the full [ __ ] patois sundae
the [ __ ] best brothers looking Cory
and Chad my brothers and brothers on
eBay because it was roughly Mays
birthday yesterday look at the flying to
what the Florida for three days came
back with no son I'm talking about this
is what i'm talking about you bad
[ __ ] I'm in Denver this week
but the shows are gone
the week after that I'm in Huntsville
Alabama where's Leonard skin it with the
guns I'm smoking some redneck wheat
dipped in diesel [ __ ] fuel you follow
me you don't know what reefer is this
dipped in diesel and you're sitting
there listen to Johnny Cash thinking
anyway huh who gives a [ __ ]
wants a bunk in here my [ __ ]
apologies I've been here acting like a
[ __ ] you want the big meal with a
little meal let me do one from them and
leave let's do you gotta stretch the
lungs i you've been [ __ ] around
JetBlue [ __ ] way up they held them over
in New Orleans I hope you gave 300 is
I'm saying Doug you think I'm gonna
interrupt your Sunday afternoon to waste
your [ __ ] time don't waste my time I
don't waste your time in this damn Oh a
few people they threw away the copy that
Godfather cuz Marlon Brando's gay he
sucked Superman's dick the other guy
from Cuban I had the big dick I got the
article at the house he suck Superman's
dick he went to see him perform
he became him with two chicks he dropped
the two chicks off and he sucked
Superman's dick in 1951 and Cuba can you
believe that [ __ ] I lit it on fire we'll
save the rest for later tonight we're
going deep deep deep in the murky waters
at the Comedy Store tonight it's sold
out we got [ __ ] knives oh [ __ ] I told
you he had ele that's what I like about
my mood shall be friend he's always got
a roadmap yeah Lupo you by Joe's give
them on our friend list I'll be back in
two minutes
by the way you want to slice you give an
uber driver a slice no suck your dick
ten times you don't say Oh
a little Def Leppard on a Sunday track
you know gamers Ralphie may want to
charge my iPod you know I like music so
[Music]
he goes oh look at lien [ __ ]
hibernate what's he doing hydrate and
hydrate I'm sorry I couldn't think of
the word
[Music]
looking good looking good on the sponsor
back looking good
cuz you're filled with sperm that's what
I figured out those spots come out
because you haven't shot a load in two
weeks oh I've been shooting long have
you been masturbating you so my
flashlight is in from what you got to do
is whack off with the [ __ ] hot water
on your desk oh man why y'all pushing
you bang one out forget about it turn it
call it let's do it
[Music]
all this little meals on fire today here
we go take a look into my eyes we're
gonna handsome [ __ ] what that's
what the Sun does he toughen your
[ __ ] lung there you go listen to him
he's a savage by the way my man's book
came out the corporation by Vijay was
his name English
TJ English pre-order on Amazon March
20th I'm going to the book signing in
New York City details coming soon you
know we don't [ __ ] around I got my hands
in a couple of things you follow me no I
got some different with you last week I
had a bud that fella I was busy that was
the morning so a bud was in my sweat
jacket and the whole container found the
busy and the peak like a half inch in I
saved three quarters of the people but
the but that got wet I pulled aside like
two weeks I brought in here we smoked it
we got so [ __ ] high
[Music]
[Music]
all cheering all [ __ ] really kill this
meal let's do this thing kill this
[ __ ] meal no drama here we go
[Music]
oh [ __ ] William if he let me tell you
summat that smoke comes to the phone and
you [ __ ] your wife tonight you might
have twins that's how we do it here
always always [ __ ] around taking it
to the next level you guys are family
look at this this is beautiful here they
even pull it around ah there you go
that's the magic [ __ ] that's the alarm
[Music]
because we put the [ __ ] pieces
together I'm a little slow
I take the podcast escape
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
all right you bad [ __ ] you ain't
Joey you left me hanging now I'm being a
[ __ ] host I'm pouring out [ __ ]
bong it's here like I'm at a homeless
shelter you know I'm saying some people
go to homeless and give our food I give
up buckets same difference
oh boy oh yeah I got a new one for you
now ping girl until our boy I pour la
Pinta and throw our iron that means
through my dick the bullet went
yeah I'm saying it sounds a little
better in English in Spanish but you
know the same well la fingerlings all
our higher that means you're bad
[ __ ] I mean well la thing up
and throw our sorry
[Music]
Alabama March first will coming down
there and then man I act the 20th of
March one show go [ __ ] around eight
o'clock are gonna have the early in the
morning I got trying to be hanging out
all [ __ ] night jumping up and down
you know I'm saying we're here we'll
quit bondage for [ __ ] Jerry's kids
and if you got osmosis number two one
last bonding then you're gonna go to
youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz back
down sublight down that's right
youtube.com slash Joey Diaz up whatever
it listen whatever your [ __ ] find it
if you want to see some you'll find it
rather I can't find that what time is
show starts if I tell you it was a 20 in
the dark you [ __ ] fine right nobody
could find nothing I tell you half a
yard or a grandma blown and you find the
[ __ ] everybody becomes Columbus
after that you have filthy [ __ ] anyway
let's do some more reefer reefer here
yeah a juke to find the 20 in the duct
that's how he tested you that comes over
here was an Israel let's see I dropped
the 20 a [ __ ] you like blow up the
[ __ ] fuse box if I turn the light on
he's on in 20 minutes and that's a Jew
and if he's got in this pocket that
guy's uncle's in the concentration camp
they see it 20 is going home with me I'm
saying it's what you wanted it's going
in this side I didn't find out what what
are you talking about you just search me
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
youtube.com slash slash Joey Diaz five
minutes we'll see you then